Scientific Research.
I definitely believe that you ever see
trinity and be chatting around, Oh,
you know,
let's,
let's start slow because you didn't go
over so many different things in bombs
trying to ignite the atmosphere
and the 1960s. Oh No,
I know that the US air force tried to
destroy the atmosphere in 1968. Yes.
Uh, operations, starfish prime. They
actually did get a nuclear bomb.
They adopted to detonate a
nuclear bomb in the upper.
I'm trying to blow up the
rental and renovation.
They've done a lot of goofy shit.
See that's the thing.
That's why I got mad
at you and I love you.
You're a smart guy and everything
is on. You can go, listen,
you got mad at me cause we didn't
communicate all this stuff.
I know you're even better at saying it
and then you sit there because you can't
handle it and you shake it.
I can. I go now. It's not
that I can't handle it. It's,
there's two factors. One,
I don't have any time.
I don't have enough time to
go into it as much as you do.
You asked why I flipped out and got
mad at you. That's it right there. You,
every time I bring up a fucking subject,
you know all about it.
I don't know all about this fucking
know all about six shit, little shit.
You're a smart guy, Joe. Joe,
just as a Po Bullshit.
You know exactly what you're,
I don't think you're a bad guy.
You're trying to survive for you
and your family and do good, okay?
But your family,
none of us are going to make it.
There's a post human error coming.
The breakaway civilization,
the deal's been made. It's not,
it's not the third dementia.
They've made fricking deals with
interdimensional aliens. Okay,
and notice the media never industry
for that cause that's the truth.
Maybe this is true. I do not know
this and we'll get into it. Okay?
I do not know this and even these human
pig hybrids, Jamie just pulled this up.
I believe it's true. I mean, I'm sorry.
The Sandy Hook kids die.
My identity is not that I get it.
They admit five g and all the studies
La Times causes massive mutation and
cancer. Wait a minute. Wait, minute
really rattles your DNA apart.
All of our kids are under attack.
You mean five manager for allowing five
g to come in? This is the new Internet.
You know why they won't let China
put in Wapo you know, swap or major.
That's the big Chinese are on fire today.
No. Let me tell you. Gee, you're on fire.
No, Joe, Joe, the five g
you're on fire. Okay. Okay.
Maybe see article and 96 about human
animal hybrids with pigs and cows. Yes.
You've got to make you part cal. So cal
keeps you. Does it reject it or part pick.
Okay. Okay. But let me expand and,
and you know about pigs and rats
were most closely related to us.
Not even chimpanzees. That's why a
lot of the organs don't get rejected.
You know about that? Yes. Okay.
Yes. Pigs are very close to humans.
Even use pig organs and piece
will usually know everything show.
No, it's true. I mean, you
know, in a general knowledge,
you know everything I know.
No, no, no. I don't listen to it.
Let me tell you, this is literally,
we know what they're doing. She'll
just like, they say just like they say,
Oh yeah, we had human animal hybrids.
This is like fricking 39 years ago now,
23 years ago. I'm reading in the BBC
about it and go confirm attack. Okay,
and they're just floating in.
There was an article in 1999
in the Baltimore Sun and
I interviewed Nick because
she read a Dick McCutcheon and Dominic
mega. She'd know Gotti blow you away.
Who is he? His Dad was a US congressman,
got killed. His brother, US senator, he,
he like,
he should have him on the show.
They're the guys that got all the money
given to native Americans and spell his
last name. Baggage shits. It's,
it's, it's, he's good friend of mine.
Can I get them on apps? A fricking lift
flyer right now. Anyways, the point is,
so what does he do? He was telling me
all these years ago, he goes, Alex,
it isn't chemicals in the food and water.
That's child's last name again.
Beg It checked. It's not going to worry
about it. Jimmy. It's electro chemical.
Okay,
it's electro chemical,
but I'm reading and the Baltimore Sun
Aftra just had him on and thought it was
crazy.
He's giving all these patents for mind
control using wavelengths in microwaves
and I'm sitting there looking at
it and I'm reading it and I'm,
and I'm seeing it and the Baltimore
senses the CIA is testing on cell towers,
uh, wave links to calm the public
during crises. I just had baggage,
Sean with patents talking about that.
What baggage explains his,
it's not that the microwave.
I have somehow interfaced with the brain.
We already interfaced with the space
winds and all these other magnetic fields
and everything else show.
They're all just testing this stuff
and so everything they deployed,
they've got all these other technologies.
My Dad was at ut and 65 when he was in
high school. They already had CD roms,
computers,
everything.
But they had a nuclear reactor underneath
the building and what supposed to tell
them? Oh absolutely. That's
what I'm telling you.
It's a breakaway civilization dude. We
don't know what they got. We don't know.
We don't know who they are. We
don't know. The whole thing.
That's what I'm telling you is this is
hiding in plain view and that's why it's
so crazy. Imagine if you knew all this.
You're trying to tell people and they go,
Oh God,
he's doing that.
Find one thing he did it sounds
mean and make that his whole world.
So that's what I'm telling you is it's
been in the newspaper that the cell
towers are being used for mind control.
That sounds like a schizophrenia. So see,
here's a, here's where it gets
tougher. I want to see that.
How do they use this salad?
Tongs whole. I'd probably
look, here's the thing. Skits.
Listen,
here's the deal right here.
You've got a total schizophrenia that
thinks the sun is following him around
town and thinks their dog is watching
them and works for the aliens.
That's not happening.
You've got someone over here,
someone over here that believes everything
they see on Fox News. Yes. Okay. Yes.
Now questionings.
Good science is good.
Trying to figure out what's real and all
of us get freaked out in the nature of
the world. No one knows
what the university is. We
don't have all the answers.
So it kind of, people can't handle that
bigness. They can't handle that question.
I'll especially low Iq.
So they have to differentiate and create
a model that allows them to put it in
boxes so they can make it
make sense because they can't
handle it. It's like, uh,
like I say,
even top astronauts space walk for
the first time and they're out in the
universe and the whole planet's under
him. And what are they gonna do? They it,
it's mindblowing.
Well,
imagine once you realize we don't know
everything we don't understand and it's
endless and there's all this crazy crap,
people go nuts and it's
humans learn more and more.
As we become more advanced
and go to this metamorphosis,
it's going to create a giant societal
crisis where most of the people already
going to get killed. The
globalist understand that
in the birth of this planet,
this new species. And so they decided
to take control, make it scientific,
stun everyone in Denim Noun so they can
scientifically try to orderly carry this
operation out. But then I go,
wait a minute, you're detonate.
And over a hundred dollars in bonds,
the upper atmosphere to see if you could
ignite the atmosphere destroying the
earth. Yeah, but that
was in the 60s I know,
but what I'm telling you is the
same professors train people,
but those people are dead.
The people that detonated those hydrogen
bombs in the 60s they're dead now.
Does not. We're not dealing with
the same human beings. I'm with you.
I know people in a lot of ways or more
immoral now I think I agree with you in
some ways that everything
evolves and things get better.
This is one of my arguments
about operation Northwoods
that if they were able to
push operation Northwoods
and get it signed by the
Joint Chiefs of staff in 1962
was it 62 if they were able to do that
and no one went to jail and no one got
arrested for proposing that they were
going to arm Cuban friendlies and have
them bomb Guantanamo Bay and blow
up a Cuban jetliner and, and, and,
and shoot people in movie theaters. Yes.
And schools. Yes. That things evolve.
Things evolve. And if unchecked,
and obviously that was unchecked,
no one went to jail for that. No one
got, you know, even PBS covered it.
Like I never even knew this.
Let's read this one here.
The significance of the research he
explained is that although the cell phone
power is low,
electromagnetic radiation can nevertheless
have an effect on mental behavior
when transmitting at the proper frequency.
What does this article Jamie Scientific,
American and scientific American at
the title mind control by cell phone.
So really does have an effect. They
did a whole study. Let's go further.
So there is,
so what do you think that they're
making this classified last year,
a 37 page,
she IAA manual from the 1970s where they
were putting up shell towers that look
like trees already testing at
neighborhoods. Okay, the judge,
can I shut the phone,
tracks you and watches you and
controls you and surveil shoe.
You think that that,
that it's one way,
but beyond that it's a microwave relay
relay system they can manipulate and then
the towers are even more powerful. So
this is a device given to us by the gotch.
Okay.
Given to us by the technology that
that the breakaway government,
NASA has developed that you don't just
think they made up themselves. Right.
What do you mean? Who Do
you think made it up? Well,
when you're ready to get to it,
I want listeners to understand something.